los haga pan dos como éste son estas
maravillosas flores que de pronto con
las primeras lluvias de la primavera
empiezan a aparecer
y aparecen y se abren y florecen y duran
mucho tiempo y cuando empieza a llegar
el otoño van perdiendo sus hojas y se
van quedando como testigos fieles de lo
que ocurre y observan el mundo
los agapantos vienen de sudáfrica
tienen ciertas peculiaridades una de
ellas es que es durante diferentes
épocas se utilizaron para darle la
bienvenida a los niños al mundo e
incluso se utilizaban también como parte
de algunos rituales para las mujeres
embarazadas cada tanto sabe más es un
hombre que proviene de dos voces griegas
de ágape y de altos y es por eso que su
nombre es el de la flor del amor
los haga pan dos cuando empiezan a
florecer como habían lo capto gilberto o
limpio en esta foto
son unas flores que comienzan con un
ejercicio de desprendimiento de cada uno
de sus filamentos que en conjunto
comienzan a hacer como esta fuerza para
salir de ese botón no es que florezcan
de manera individual en sus filamentos
sino lo hacen en conjunto lo hacen todos
juntos lo hacen interconectados gracias
a la estructura en la que se basa esta
misma comprensión sobre el conjunto es
la comprensión que nos viene elevada del
pensamiento lacandón el pensamiento
lacandón entonces
quiénes son los lacandones los
lacandones son esta comunidad
maravillosa que habita en el sureste de
méxico es una comunidad maya que vive
dentro de la selva lacandona y que tiene
una cosmovisión sumamente rica dentro de
esta cosmovisión consideran que todos
los seres de la naturaleza estamos
profundamente interconectados que todos
somos parte de un todo conjunto que no
somos parte de individuos separados
aislados sino que estamos unidos y es
por eso que les traigo esta frase que me
parece maravillosa de uno de sus grandes
portadores y en esta frase que para eso
puedo decir que también me apoyo un poco
como material didáctico en nuestro
escenario lo que dice es todos los seres
vivientes estamos relacionados amarrados
desde la misma raíz cuando el dios de
los dioses hizo las estrellas las hizo
de arena y piedras y la sembró las
raíces de cada estrella son las raíces
un árbol cuando se cayó un árbol una
estrella cae del cielo y quiero que
observen entonces esta visión panorámica
es una visión profundamente abierta
profundamente extendida profundamente
consciente porque tener esta cosmovisión
no solamente es una forma de pensar es
una forma de vivir de qué forma entonces
interactuamos con nosotros cuando
tenemos una visión tan panorámica
incluso de qué forma dormimos por
ejemplo en el caso de los lacandones no
duermen tal vez como en el resto del
mundo no que dormimos nuestras horitas
corridas sino que duermen espaciadamente
y se despiertan porque se saben
responsables del resto de los seres
porque saben que su presencia en vigilia
también implica estar ahí atentos del
equilibrio del bienestar y del cuidado
el vivir con esta conciencia entonces
impactan en la forma en la que también
cuidamos nuestras palabras nuestros
actos nuestros pensamientos nuestros
vínculos nuestros silencios nos volvemos
mucho más conscientes
y esto nos hace también tener la
conciencia de nuestra interconexión esta
interconexión panorámica a veces la
perdemos dentro del ejercicio de la
emergencia y del ejercicio de lo
cotidiano pasamos de lo panorámico más
bien a un movimiento sobre lo estrecho y
que quiero decir con este movimiento del
estrecho vivimos en un ejercicio
emergente urgente en donde lo que
tenemos que hacer es llegar al trabajo
después de tal vez a atravesar el
tráfico lo que tenemos que hacer es
cumplir con los objetivos llegar al
número no perder de vista no sé tal vez
las metas que tenemos y en este
ejercicio de lo urgente vamos perdiendo
esa conciencia esa conciencia de
interconexión y vamos más bien
convenciendo nos entre todos de una
conciencia de lo rápido de lo emergente
de que estamos aquí para algo inminente
y este ejercicio de estrechez con lo que
se vincula de manera directa es también
con una conciencia de individualidad
creo que lo que debo alcanzar
algo que alcanzó solo en solitario que
mis objetivos que son unos objetivos
determinados solamente los voy a
alcanzar si me dirijo a ellos pero ya no
en comunidad no como esa imagen del haga
tanto si no es algo que voy a alcanzar
solamente yo y empiezo a trabajar en un
ejercicio también de una competitividad
quiero que observen por un momentito mis
manos mis manos están unidas en un
ejercicio de paridad porque están al
mismo nivel pero en el momento en el que
yo empiezo a separarlas y unas toma una
posición de superioridad se desconecta
este es el ejercicio en el que caemos
dentro de toda esta este ciclo y esta
comprensión de la búsqueda de los
objetivos en solitario me desconecto de
los otros es una superioridad en donde
trató de diferenciar me porque creo
ciertamente en este ciclo de implosión y
esa diferenciación es lo que me va a dar
el principio del éxito creo que esa
diferenciación y ese colocarme por
encima de los demás es lo que me va a
dar ese sentido de baldía
es lo que me va a dar como este premio
ese reconocimiento pero al hacerlo
efectivamente alcanzó una de las grandes
consecuencias y esa consecuencia es un
proceso de aislamiento un proceso de
aislamiento natural en donde generó una
desconexión
esta desconexión a que me lleva es una
desconexión en donde más bien tengo
relaciones superficiales y pensemos lo
nosotros en nuestro día a día con
cuántas personas interactuamos a través
de nuestras redes sociales a través de
nuestros vínculos digitales diariamente
con cuántas personas pero a qué
profundidad tal vez a nivel de extensión
con muchas pero con cuentas
efectivamente hablamos de lo que
sentimos con cuántas superamos esos
monosílabos con cuántas pasamos de decir
estoy bien gracias y tú con cuántas
realmente nos abrimos para expresar cuál
fue mi emoción cuál es mi deseo en qué
momento de crisis de estoy si tengo tal
vez las mismas dudas del otro gran parte
de esta de esta crisis y este
cuestionamiento lo vivimos en realidad
de una manera solitaria en este mundo
desconectados
ante esto
empezamos a generar algo que es la
fantasía de control y por qué le digo
fantasía porque quiero que imaginen que
es algo que solamente habita en nuestra
mente es una fantasía una construcción y
esta fantasía de control es muy parecida
no sé si alguna vez dentro de su
infancia o su adolescencia y si no nunca
es tarde para tener esta lectura que es
muy interesante y tal vez es una de esas
lecturas que implica relecturas alicia
en el país de las maravillas' ese conejo
blanco con esta prisa con esta
inminencia con este nunca parar con este
nunca hay tiempo nos lleva a esa
fantasía de control en donde comenzamos
a construir como ciertos patrones en los
que queremos centrar y comenzamos a
hablar de los deberías ya qué me refiero
con esos deberías los deberías que
empezamos a colocar por ejemplo cuando
estudiamos una carrera universitaria es
que tú deberías de saber no sé a los 19
a los 20 años a los 18 cuál va a ser la
vocación a la que te vas a dedicar toda
la vida qué miedo
es que tú deberías de dedicarte a eso
toda la vida
o por ejemplo al salir de la carrera yo
debería de entrar a trabajar en tal
empresa y después de entrar en esa
empresa después de dos años yo debería
de escalar a tal posición
antes de los 30 yo debería de tener una
gerencia o yo debería de tener tal
cantidad de dinero en mi cuenta de banco
estos deberías que son rígidos que son
expectativas vacías pero dolorosas son
deberías que van controlando nuestra
mente y nuestra vida generando esta
fantasía una fantasía que creemos real
como si estuviéramos dentro de un sueño
no lo cuestionamos no dudamos de él y
más bien lo tomamos como si fuera cierto
y después de los deberías que colocó
sobre mí ya creen que voy a hacer voy a
empezar a colocar debería sobre ti
tú deberías de hacer esto
yo no me puedo permitir tú no te puedes
permitir y empieza una lucha para que
para tratar de comprender cómo es que el
mundo no se ajusta a mis deberías
yo sé que suena muy neurótico pero es
real
y así somos
una lucha por decir porque no puedo
controlar a los demás porque no puedo
controlar que los demás se comporten
como yo necesito que comporte se
comporten porque si voy con prisa a una
junta a este señor se le ocurre
atravesarse en mi carril que no sabe que
voy a una junta
y así como ese ejemplo pequeño lo
podemos colocar en muchas otras cosas
dentro de nuestro día a día
generamos una fantasía de control pero
cuál es el siguiente paso cuando esta
fantasía en algún sentido se cumple
porque no se va a cumplir del todo pero
cuando esta fantasía en algún sentido se
cumple que ocurre nos encadenamos a ella
porque después que voy a buscar si ya
cumplí el objetivo a los 20 o a los 30
de esa gerencia pues primero sostén la
entonces cualquier cosa que se acerque y
que la ponga en riesgo va a ser para mí
un verdadero atentado y voy a sufrir
porque voy a tratar de conservar la
intacta
pero más allá de eso también se presenta
otro problema porque entonces cuál va a
ser mi reto para los 35
que me voy a poner como siguiente
objetivo y para los 40 y para los 45
entonces efectivamente entramos en un
ciclo de implosión
que nos genera un alto nivel de
sufrimiento y de estrés pero el otro
punto y si no lo logro
si no cumplo con esas expectativas que
ocurre aparecen algunas voces como por
ejemplo no soy suficiente no cumplí con
lo que los demás esperaban de mí seguro
hay algo mal en mí
seguramente los demás no van a querer
vincularse conmigo
y empiezo también a sufrir entonces no
hay fórmula ganadora dentro de este
modelo
y por tanto empezamos a caer en un en un
vinculo desvinculante empezamos a
aislarnos y empezamos a dar lugar a una
sutil y constante y quiero enfocarme en
esto sutil y constante crisis de soledad
porque es útil y constante voy a poner
una analogía imagínense hoy en día en
tanto trabajo y estudio remoto que están
ustedes en casa y están tomando tal vez
una clase tal vez una junta están
hablando con un amigo están viendo una
serie y de pronto hay una gotera en la
regadera
podría pasar poco apercibida no podría
pasar desapercibida para ustedes podrían
no darse cuenta de que está ahí y
podrían seguir su día platicando viendo
su serie pasándose la muy bien pero
cuando llega la noche y cuando empieza a
llegar el silencio con la noche
empiezan ustedes a escuchar esa gotera
y esa gotera algo tan pequeñito tan
sutil porque una gota es sutil se acaba
convirtiendo en una tortura
es agotador
es algo casi insostenible a eso es a lo
que me refiero cuando utilizo estas
estas estas palabras una sutil y
constante crisis de soledad de desamparo
de exposición y de vergüenza porque es
útil
no es algo contundente que llegue a
nosotros no es que me sienta desamparada
todo el día pero me siento desamparada
cada vez que pongo por ejemplo un punto
de referencia en mis redes sociales y me
doy cuenta de que tal vez la foto que
alguien subió en un ejercicio aparente
de plena felicidad no coincide con esta
sensación de vacío por no alcanzar el
objetivo a mis 30
a las 30 de ustedes yo tengo mucho más
que eso ok entonces quiero que observen
que esto es algo sutil y esto como se
observa o cómo se manifiesta bueno
desafortunadamente
esto se manifiesta hoy en día
con algunos datos que observamos la
depresión y la ansiedad sigue a la
vanguardia de nuestros tiempos con una
de las principales causas de invalidez
porque efectivamente no solamente está
afectando a los adultos sino está
afectando directamente a los jóvenes en
los últimos 50 años podemos observar que
los índices de pues de desarrollo a
nivel económico en los países no están
siendo coincidentes con los índices de
felicidad y que los índices de depresión
están creciendo muchísimo y esto
comienza a aparecer a través de algunas
voces si ustedes de pronto se preguntas
cuáles serían esas goteras esas gotas
que caen pues son a través de estos
pensamientos que se dan de manera
automática en nosotros y surgen
silenciosamente en esa noche aparecen en
nuestra mente no necesitan aparecer nos
los platicamos con nosotros no es algo
que lleguemos al café a contarlo con un
amigo no le digo podemos sentarnos a
hablar de las voces que escucho
seguramente me vería con cara como ve
has pensado en ir a recibir algún tipo
de ayuda
y estas dos las tenemos todos
sería fundamental que nos psico educarán
respecto a ellas pero estas voces son
las que empiezan a aparecer
continuamente
aparecen una y otra vez poco a poco
estoy perdiendo el control de mi vida no
sé en qué momento ya no pude con esto
porque estoy incapaz de relajarme
diferentes voces que todos hemos
escuchado el tema es que llega un
momento en el que se escuchan y se
escuchan y se escuchan más a menudo y
esto nos va volviendo efectivamente
mucho menos hábiles para adaptarnos a
nuestra realidad ya las exigencias de
nuestro día y nos va aislando cada vez
más cómo podemos resolverlas este es
esta es la realidad que tenemos cómo
podemos resolver las las podemos
resolver porque las respuestas la
tenemos dentro de nosotros y si las
podemos resolver como a través de algo
que se llama la habilidad esencial que
es la habilidad esencial del ser humano
es estar consciente y es ser consciente
la habilidad de esencial consiste en
esto la habilidad esencial consiste en
regresar a nuestro presente detener por
un momento los pensamientos darme cuenta
de que todas las personas que yo tengo a
mi alrededor observar que estoy aquí
así se detiene esa gotera y después de
darme cuenta de que estoy consciente
avanzar y observar en mi interior que
efectivamente hay una gran cantidad de
personas que me han acompañado y me ha
de las cuales soy yo soy el resultado
pensemos en cosas tan pequeñas como por
ejemplo el último trabajo escolar que
ustedes hicieron y que ustedes
entregaron la cantidad de voces que
vienen en ese trabajo desde los autores
que leyeron hasta la maestra que les
enseñó a escribir la genética de la que
son resultados la cantidad de personas
que los han acompañado la cultura que
ustedes de la cual ustedes son hoy
resultado algo tan sencillo como la ropa
la ropa que traen puesta el día de hoy
para esta plática la cantidad de manos
involucradas para que se pudiera llegar
al urdimbre que dio a ese suéter o esa
camisa entonces en cada uno de estos
actos miren en su interior y observen
que la naturaleza que tenemos es una
naturaleza de interconexión pero ustedes
me podrán decir cómo es que nosotros lo
podemos mirar bueno en nuestro sistema
tenemos un elemento fundamental un
elemento que ya aristóteles hace 2500
años se preguntaba que existía con el
todo son políticos pero hoy nos lo
muestra la ciencia
que la evolución del nervio vago
polinizado al corazón este nervio vago y
el iniciado al corazón a qué se refiere
se refiere a que tenemos una
serie de sistemas maravillosos de
conducta de afiliación de vínculo y de
encuentro somos seres para el encuentro
somos seres para la empatía para la
gratitud para la compasión para la
relación y para el vínculo
nunca estamos solos acuérdense de eso
qué
[Aplausos]